Now it's time for our wrap up. Let's give
it everything we've got. Ready? Begin.
Alley-alley-alley-alley-oop on amateurs. Air
above all and any actors is average.
Big barbarian basically beasting. Biters get
blown up being brave, beatings.
Casually, I chef cash cheddar. Fools get casualties
and caught off guard with chin music.
Dirty when I drop dimes, damaging the dang
earth. Devastate the defense, detonate, danger.
Entertainer entertaining everyone, every mass.
Enemies is envious ain't even peep the elbow pass
Fire en fuego, flick of the wrist, foes in.
Fear of the fury, left flattened and frozen.
Gloves off for the glass jaws by the goons.
G.O.A.T. of all G.O.A.T.'s, gone giddy getting through.
Human joy stick, heating up, heat check BLAM.
Hitting hard, hella hyped, hero going HAM.
I'm isolated on islands. It's over, it's over.
Ice in your veins getting colder.
Juke, jock, jerk to those who aren't worthy.
Jamming through my journey in a jet black jersey
King Kong of K.O's, kid kiss the ring. Knuckle
up now with the knuckle buck King.
Let me live a long life, leading with my laces
out. Right now losers look up, cause it's
lights out.
My moves marvelous, money shot, massive. Main
event, moon-shot, MVP, master.
Nails in the coffin, knots in their knees.
Triumph. Nutmeg through the knees, nothing
but nylon.
Opposition off on the ropes in the octagon.
One-two, punched out, lights going off and on
Pillow pick passes of prolific poetry. Power
plays, pick-pocketing petty phonies.
Quest for the cup, it's quantum y'all, quote
me. Quiet all quitters feeling qualms when were quarreling.
Raw ringside riots relish and remain. Rallying.
Ruff rated rhymes make it rain.
Swishing on simple soft suckers, spit swag.
Slice, dice, shimmy, nothing but net. Splash.
Turnt up. Taken out timid minds. Twister.
Leave them turnt out , they are truck stick victims
Unstoppable ups, stay uninvolved. Unanimous.
Universal. Year of the underdog.
Vicious & vital shots, victories calling.
Volley y'all out victorious velocity.
Bob & weave well, wide receiving words woven.
Moon walk when I whip. Get the world open.
X-celling, X-treme. X-tra X-plosive. X-hilarating,
X-out competition so quick.
Yolo pass rhymes, y'all young bucks fall.
Yoga stretch minds yelling yiggy yes y'all.
Zero, zero, zero on the clock, games over.
Zooming to the zenith. zero-out. In my zone.
ZONING!!!!!!!!
Ha. Ha. Ha. Ha. Good. Can you say it faster?